hi friends welcome welcome back to my
channel essence of Earth I am your
hostess with the mostess Miss Nikita and
y'all know over here we're going to
focus on everything that's going to help
you improve the quality of your life I'm
doing something a little different today
I'm going to give you a book review um I
am a lover of books about health and um
things like that so I read a lot of
books and I was reading through this
book last night because I am in the
process process of writing my own book
and um I was getting some information I
remembered this had some really good
information so I kind of want to come on
today I'll just give you a book review
um and the name of wait I can't believe
I always forget this but before I get
into the book review we got to be
friends right so you you y'all know the
routine by now I'm sure you do but you
got to go ahead on and um subscribe and
click the notification Bell so you'll be
notified every time I post and lucky for
you that's like every day every other
day now so go ahead moment of
silence thank you all right so let's get
into it and first of
all BR I love the the title of this book
Dead Doctors Don't
Li I know it kind of got like a a sting
to it but
y'all know them doctors be
lying y'all know them doctors be lying
y'all be like why he why my daugh a tell
me this why my daugh tell me why my
daugh do this why my daugh a do that
y'all know daughters be lying okay uh
but in this
book okay let's see if I had to read it
if I had to read the book
um I would probably read it out of a
seven out of 10 um I have ADHD I have
undiagnosed ADHD and I'm probably going
to create a an herbal formula or tonic
for that I just haven't gotten around to
it yet but it's in the works okay cuz
and I will be the first one using it but
I have undiagnosed ADHD so I really um
have to read stuff that really keeps me
engaged right otherwise I'll be like why
the heck am I reading this like this is
this isn't keeping me engaged
it's kind of boring I need a Twist in
the the storyline or the
information um while I do
appreciate uh him first of all did doors
Don't Lie by Dr Joel D wallik and Dr
Milan okay this is what it looks like
and of course you can support me by um
subscribing and then uh you can get the
book from my Amazon store um and I do
get paid commissions for that so thank
thank you if you're interested in
getting this book um but yeah while I do
appreciate you know learning the
backstory
behind behind you know like the history
of how he got to where he was and what
he did while I do appreciate that uh
just in the book it was I like the book
was about
that now he did mention some things like
pretty much how a lot of the doctors
like they die actually before a lot of
their patients because of their
lifestyle uh and stuff like that not all
doctors but he was just he mentioned
that several time which is how he got
the title dead dacts don't lie um but a
lot of the doctors they end up dying
before their patients or dying at an
early age um and then he he he had his
backstory and it was just it was just
really long um and that kind of bored me
me like I wanted it to hurry up um he
went through a lot of Trials throughout
you
know getting to the point where he has
this huge company where he's selling
like minerals real minerals uh for
health like 99
99 um 99 essential minerals or something
like that I actually bought it plant
minerals and I also bought his selenium
from his company but understanding his
backstory he was started out like
working with animals and um finding out
that a a lot of the same symptoms that
we have as humans they act they also
show up in in animals um so you know him
being able to see that and one become a
veterinarian and all of the trials and
obstacles that he went through to get
there and you know people not really
wanting to take him serious um and stuff
like that and then
um be just becoming so good at it and
understanding how essential vitamins uh
minerals are to to certain symptoms that
you're having kind of like linking them
um so he performed like thousands and
thousands of um autopsies on animals so
he was able to kind of you know say take
this vitamin for this take this take
this mineral for this you need this for
this you know and he was able to do that
by working with animals pretty much um
so much so that he had this company I
can't remember the name of it but I'm
going to get I'm going to find it out
for you but Dr Joe wall and then I can
I'll put it up here so you'll see it um
I think it's plant-based minerals or
something like that but I tried it um it
was good I just I drank it or I just
added it to water um do I feel like I
felt a difference from it I don't um I
just felt good knowing that I was
getting the minerals so so that was good
but um I think the best part of this
book which is why it was so hard to go
any lower than a seven is because the
end of it
like at the end the end was my
favorite um just because it got to what
I was interested in right and that's um
the minerals and that's learning about
um you know different ailments right
because that's that's what I'm in the
business of it's herbs and minerals and
learning how I could help someone um who
has an issue a health issue um and
wanting to be able to help them so um oh
my God something in my eye it's probably
my my
weave okay but anyway so that was my
favorite part it really was so I um
highlighted some sections on here cuz I
wanted to go over some of my favorites
and um I guess so we'll see and in the
book
um listen to listen to this he says some
79 minerals have been detected in animal
and human tissue blood liver muscle
brain their presence in the tissues
fulfills the first criteria for calling
a mineral and essential nutrient
literally thousands of studies provide
additional support for considering 60 of
these 79 nutrients to be
essential these studies were done on
animals at every stage of Life pregnant
suckling weaning weanling and mature
furthermore these studies were carried
out on animals and virtually every
description laboratory mice rats rabbits
hamsters guinea pigs habit rabbits dogs
cats pigs sheeps cattle chickens turkeys
and dugs these minerals are considered
essential because they are known to act
as co-actors for DNA RNA
enzymes enzyme systems or co-actors for
vitamins so then he lists all of these
vitamins
okay okay so let's look at one that I I
have
here common calcium deficiencies
okay now when he when he mentions like
the element the calcium I mean he goes
into like all of the history of that
mineral or that element mineral
element but listen so common calcium
deficiencies
osteoporosis dog work wers hump lordosis
compression factors spontaneous
fractures receding gums like who would
have known that I don't is your dentist
going to tell you that you know what I'm
saying receding gums um
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
hypertension hypertension right
insomnia kidney stones bone spurs
calcium deposits cramps and Twitches
PMS did you know that PMS sciatica back
pain Bell's posy
ttis um spinal stenosis osteofibrosis
panic attacks elevated blood calcium and
prolonged clotting time who would who
would have known that like that's why I
like reading books because there like
you you're not going to get this
information from your doctor I'm sorry
like your doctor isn't going to tell you
that you know what I'm saying and it
sucks that it has to be this way but
it's the absolute truth um but what else
is in here I I have something else like
look
y'all like this was my favorite part I
couldn't rate it any lower than the
seven I could not
because cuz of this stuff right here
this I love this stuff so listen to what
he has to say about calcium is the most
abundant mineral in the human body the
average male has 1,200 G and the average
female has 1,000 G Count calcium makes
up 2% of the adult body weight water
makes up 65 to 75% calcium also composes
up to 39% of the total mineral reserves
of the body Ash 99% of body calcium is
found in the bones and teeth the other
1% is found in the blood extracellular
fluids and within and within cells where
it is a co-actor and activator for
numerous enzymes
that that was it that wasn't
it listen calcium is mainly absorbed in
the duodenum where the environment is
still acid once the food in the
intestine becomes alkaline absorption
drops calcium is absorbed from the small
intestines by active cellular transport
and by simple diffusion metallic calcium
absorption may be limited to 10% or less
and is affected by many substances in
the gut calcium is highly absorbable up
to 98% in the organically bound plant
derived cidal mineral mineral and water
soluble chelated form that is the name
of the product that he sells it's called
um plant derived colloidal mineral and
water soluble chelated
form causes of Calcium deficiency right
um include a lack of vitamin D so does a
def deficiency so does a deficiency of
stomach acid like I was like
wow how could those two be related right
uh lack of stomach acid often the lack
of stomach acid or hydro hydro Chlor
hydria results from a
restricted salt intake lactose
intolerance celiac disease high fat diet
and low protein intake and High um fiate
consumption can lead to Calcium
deficiency this is so cool like
seriously phytic acid is a phosphorus
containing acid compound found in the
brand of grains and seeds as well as
stems of plants oatmeal and whole wheat
especially contain phytic acid wow I I
just love stuff like this I
do I really do what else do we have
some um I have magnesium deficiency
diseases right asthma
anorexia how you put those two together
mag um anorexia anorexia menstrual
migraines growth failure neuromuscular
problems
depression the Tremors vertigal
calcification of arterial
media malignant calcification of soft
tissues like
wow what else is in here and listen
selenium deficiencies oh my God this is
what I was looking up the other day for
my book um I really want to read the
whole thing but I don't know if this is
going to be too much but this was like
great where do I want to start okay I
want to start
here selenium deficiency diseases
okay listen to
this again
anemia right age spots and liver spots
he mentioned something specifically
about liver
spots I'm going to have to read that um
fatigue muscular weakness fibromyalgia
scoliosis muscular distrophy
cardiomyopathy heart palpitations atrial
filation liver curosis pancreatitis
pancreatic atrophy infertility low birth
weight High infant mortality SIDS sudden
infant death
syndrome cystic fibrosis and then he has
indirect results here
HIV and then he has in parenthesis
increased rate of conversion to AIDS and
transmission to fetus lugar's disease MS
Alzheimer's and cancer
selenium deficiency can result in
infertility in both men and women
congenital uh selenium deficiency during
pregnancy can result in a wide variety
of problems ranging from miscarriage low
birth weight High infant mortality
cystic fibrosis I just mentioned all of
these
above in young adult selenium deficiency
appears as anemia chronic fatigue
muscular weak weakness um cardiomyopathy
is quite common in young athletes such
as basketball and football players this
is good for like people with like
athletes kids CH children who are
athletes and stuff
um uh basketball football players in
high school college universities and
professional levels because of selenium
deficiency as are multiple sclerosis and
liver curosis so cool but there was one
thing that really stuck out about
selenium and
HIV um listen to what he
says the School of Pharmacy from the
University of Georgia released a report
in August of
1994 that concludes that a human
selenium deficiency is related to the
clinical onset of full-blown AIDS in
chronically infected HIV
patients according to the their report
HIV requires large amounts of selenium
for replication in selenium deficient
patients the virus competes with the
patient for The Limited amounts of
available selenium the HIV patient
actually dies from a chronic selenium
deficiency I can't say this word
inpathy liver therosis or
cardiomyopathy longterm term HIV
patients 20 years or more that never
developed full-blown clinical AIDS had
supplemented with large amounts of
selenium like wow who's going to tell
you that you you literally going to have
to read about you have to read about
this stuff in order to learn it like
that's why I'm I'm just like an average
reader I just love it um so then he has
a bunch of like issues here problems or
symptoms that one may have and then he
he goes into telling you uh what to do
so let's see if we can find a
uh so let's look at this one here he
lists asthma a lot of people suffer from
asthma let's see what he says it is a
respiratory disease that is
characterized by sudden onset of closure
of bronchial tubes by
spasmodic muscles this is what he
recommends treatment should include be
betane
HCI which is hydrochloric acid
pancreatic enzymes and Ox bile at 75 to
200 mgram
each taken before meals autoimmune urine
therapy essential fatty acid at 5 gram
plant derived collidal mineral
suspensions that contain magnesium and
magnes should be taken herbs are very
useful for treating asthma with some
caution when you have allergies to
plants useful plants include
honeysuckle leaks
garlic P primose
oil or fluid extract a variety of
standard inhalers are available to cope
with sudden attacks
M and let's see what
else I'll give us one
[Music]
more I want something that's like really
common
O treatment of cancer is a a busy
procedure at best until you get it under
control it will take your full-time
effort whether you opt to to take the
cut burn or and poison route as well or
if you opt totally for alternative
therapies a useful fact to help your
thinking process is that the United
States government says that the 5year
survival rate of cancer patients has not
changed over the last 20 years despite
new techniques in surgery radi
ation and chemotherapy in fact untreated
patients as a group
survived
longer what the government doesn't tell
you is that the untreated Patient Group
includes those treated with alternative
therapies and we'll end on
that so it is a good book s out of 10
um if you enjoy learning about the you
know like the ups and
downs um of a person like their back
story go ahead the way my brain works I
need something that's going to keep me
Interest interested I need the meat I
need the the steak and potatoes up
front skip the rolls nothing to drink I
need the steak and potatoes
immediately um and that's what I need to
keep me like interested right from the
beginning um I think I mean his his
history is amazing I think he did some
great things and I just love the end of
the book cuz it got me exactly what I
wanted but again this is a seven out of
10 it is a good book it is as you can
see I still use it I use it more um as a
reference a reference book when I'm um
teaching something or helping someone um
it's something that I go back to uh and
look at so it is a book that I will most
definitely keep on my shelf